hey buddy yo Rich what's up man what is
up tonight
not not much man uh first off just
wanted to say that uh
you know I'm a recent fan and I just got
turned on to the this whole manosphere
redbill stuff back in October okay
um
just getting out of uh kind of a serious
relationship have a have a child with
the ex we were we were engaged you know
it was one of those after reading your
book recently I I realized and I'm
reading the rational mail right now I'm
almost done with it but I I realized
that the the one itis mentality that I
had you know both my parents are are
still married and
um you know just having that one
mentality like she finally
finally met a girl who who loved me for
me and uh you know I felt like I think
actually she was in my frame for a while
and then this is when I started to
realize like she just started to pushing
me away constantly and then threw me
back in and this was you know six months
six months into the relationship we find
out that we're having a kid
so my dumbass decides to propose to her
four months later thinking things will
get better that that doesn't that
doesn't work
um are you guys still together or you
said you broke up
we we are we are not together no I I I
actually walked away uh back in uh
September of 2020. left my daughter left
uh left my ex left my car with her and
everything but um you know fast forward
um we've got
five rental properties and uh I've got a
you know six six figure
job that I didn't have back then my life
is completely changed you know since
since leaving her well what I will say
to your audience is like this is
somebody that I thought was feminine and
she even told me like
she wanted to be
she was she wanted to please me you know
she wanted to make my life easy and do
all these things for me but she had all
these feminine feminist friends I mean a
few of them were covens not sure if you
know what that is but a what
coven they're like they're like witches
and it's very popular and knowing
it's right oh this is the [ __ ] that um
Aaron Cleary talks about these [ __ ]
witches yeah they all go and they do
mushrooms and practice just taking the
masculine frame away from men it's
[ __ ] crazy sorry for that yeah no
that like yeah algorithm but yeah like
you want to avoid that if you can
obviously I mean but a lot of the times
stuff like this doesn't appear right
away and and two I've always said women
you know reserve the right to change
their mind at any given time so the
chick you marry today is not the chick
you're going to be with in three or four
or ten years right right so yeah so
that's uh so that's a valid point so
um did you have a question
I was really I really just wanted to
introduce myself I talked to Jaren
um a couple couple weeks so oh okay did
you end up joining the ten percent a few
clicks away from from joining
um just trying to try to get something
buttoned up for over here my daughter's
almost three and my my ex and I just
figured out 50 50 custodial physical in
this native Massachusetts so if any of
your listeners are thinking you know
this is a liberal state it can be done
it it was a process a lot of fighting
back and forth but I just want I wanted
to tell you real quick
um I I almost I almost messed up over
the weekend
um so it was my daughter's dance recital
and uh
and her mom wanted to you know do the
dance recital and and I was like sure
you know let's let's do it my dad my dad
came and everything and uh we decided to
like take her out to dinner after and
she was all you know dressed up all nice
and stuff
a couple of drinks led to another you
know we were at dinner right near my
house and then she comes back to my
place you know my daughter's here we'd
give her a bath and she's just giving me
all these hints like all these signs and
I even I even said like listen I kind of
know what you're doing I noticed a
hundred thousand pound gorilla I'm kind
of you know I I it was it was at that
point where things probably if if our
daughter went to bed things probably
would have gone you know
ugly but it didn't it didn't happen and
I was just like afterwards I'm like man
I'm so I'm so grateful that that didn't
happen but it was it was you know it was
in that moment it was so hard not to
admit look it's it's pretty common for
that uh to go down
um she's obviously seeing your new life
you've got a bunch of doors you know you
got rental income income's gone up for
you
um you've become a lot more attractive
to her uh obviously but you saw what
happened last time you got involved with
her in her relationship you went through
betaization you turn in a bit of a [ __ ]
right yeah
so 100 100
but I mean like she is your kid's mother
so you know make sure you have a good
relationship it's just I would not
recommend you know going I've seen guys
leave marriages or get thrown out of
marriages and then remarry the same
woman again
or get or get involved with her or live
with her or have another kid with her
it's like it never works out it's like
round two of more [ __ ]
yeah I'm not gonna lie I mean there are
there are times where when she when she
shows me signs of just like being nice
and
things that you know I was attracted to
when we were together I I won't lie to
you like I I think about you know like
what what if this could what if we can
make this work for you know for our
child for the bit for the sake of our
child right but at the end of the day
it's not all of her friends are witches
dude like like what else do you need me
to tell you no I I dude I'm I'm I'm a
year removed from literally like
convincing myself like
like a year ago I was like I need to get
this woman back you know for the sake of
my child and uh and a lot a lot of [ __ ]
a lot of stuff has happened and changed
but I'm still you know there are moments
where I get I get like weak in the knees
you know but well you're only going to
get weak in the knees if you don't have
other options in your phone
and um I haven't been I saw some other
options and then you won't be looking at
her as an option
yeah and what after reading your book
and you know trying to look in the
mirror and say like where are you like
if you're a sixth and stay off the apps
right like I mean I'm I'm trying to be I
I think that I Pro I'm probably I mean
I've got the money I've got you know
um I go to the gym every day
um but um I don't know if like I'm
really just working on the mental stuff
right like my my two and a half year
olds pretty important to me but at the
same time like I I also want to have a
personal life I'm in the South Shore of
Boston and there's purple hair gorillas
everywhere and there's not not that many
you know options I'm like 20 20 miles
away from Boston which is like the cream
of the crop and it's tough for me to get
there so it's like yeah I'm just I'm
just trying to like well 20 miles ain't
much but uh yeah like you've got to get
yourself some better options than um
than a a [ __ ] witch basically I hear
you yeah I'm uh I'm a I'm looking
forward to joining the community man I
just wanted to say hello your book has
really helped me a lot and uh I
appreciate that man thank you thank you
so much all right hey guys I really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out